bonsoir à tous et à toutes je vais
commencer ce tedx en nous racontant une
histoire
alors c'est l'histoire d'un petit enfant
de onze ans qui a de grosses difficultés
scolaires en mathématiques et ces
professeurs avaient l'habitude de lui
répéter depuis son plus jeune âge qu'il
était nul qui n'allait jamais y arriver
et que ça n'allait jamais être possible
pour lui de s'en sortir dans la vie et
un jour lors d'une réunion de fin
d'année scolaire avec les parents
d'élèves donc l'élève était là et les
professeurs se sont permis de dire aux
parents qui devrait sûrement allé dans
une école spécialisée pour les enfants à
problèmes
et à partir de ce jour là cet enfant
s'est retrouvé choqué et sa l'amener à
devenir totalement inconscient
scolairement c'est à dire que le simple
fait pour lui d'aller à l'école le
stressait et le faisait paniquer au plus
haut
et sept enfants dont je vous ai parlé et
bat en réalité c'était moi je ne pense
pas être le seul à avoir ancré ce genre
de croyance
j'imagine que vous aussi ça vous est
déjà arrivé dans votre vie
d'entendre un commentaire quelqu'un vous
dire quelque chose qui vous a marqué et
qui s'est transformé en frein dans votre
vie vous invite simplement à garder
cette croyance négatives dans une partie
de votre tête
car nous y reviendrons c'est à l'heure
alors une croyance qu'est ce que c'est
une croyance c'est quelque chose que
l'on vous dit qui peut être négatifs ou
positifs comme par exemple tu es nul en
maths ou encore tu est excellent dans
tel ou tel domaine ce n'est pas parce
que une personne à de la facilité en
mathématiques qui est là la science
infuse
chaque personne a sa logique et se
laisser influencer par les professeurs
n'est en aucun cas la solution
comme le design thain si vous jugez un
poisson à sa capacité à grimper à un
arbre alors il livra toute sa vie en
croyant qu'il est stupide
et aujourd'hui on sait que les enfants
de la naissance jusqu'à 10 12 ans en
moyenne sont hyper influençable et
pourquoi car c'est à ce moment là
précisément qu'ils sont dans les ondes
delta était à celle qui exprime l'état
d'hypnose et l'état d'hypnose c'est
lorsque les portes de l'imagination sont
grandes ouvertes et plus une personne
grandit plus ça devient difficile
d'ouvrir sais pas j'ai l'habitude
d'utiliser une métaphore pour exprimer
la différence de réceptivité entre les
enfants et les adultes imaginez
maintenant qu'un enfant c'est comme une
terre fertile bien entretenues bien
arrosée et imaginer qu'un adulte
c'est comme une terre sèche
polluer dans laquelle il ya du fond
voulez maintenant vous rendre compte que
toutes les graines que vous allez sommet
sont arrêtés les croyances que vous
allez donner ou recevoir
et plus elles vont arriver sur une terre
bien entretenues bien arrosée soit en
enfants
plus elles vont s'enraciner profondément
que ce soit une croyance positives
telles qu'un fruit elle qu'un arbre ou
une croyance négative comme votre
mauvaise herbe avoue celle qui vous
posent réellement problème en tous les
cas ça va de toute façon réussir à
pousser
et maintenant je vous parlais d'une
autre croyance que j'ai reçu lorsque
j'étais jeune
alors j'ai une famille qui est unie et
j'ai une grand mère qui a des sortes de
pouvoirs de médiumnité qu'est ce que ça
signifie qu'elle peut voir l'avenir voir
à l'intérieur des joues et depuis mon
plus jeune âge elle me répétait sans
cesse
que j'avais hérité des mêmes capacités
qu'elle
est pour revenir à cette croyance ce
jour là lorsque j'avais 9 10 ans
ma grand mère m'a dit elle m'a regardé
droit dans les yeux elle m'a dit
baptiste doit sauver son frère
est ce que vous ne savez pas c'est que
j'ai un grand frère qui a
des troubles au niveau mental et sacré
simplement pour lui des difficultés au
sein de cette société si rien de grave
simplement là ça crée des difficultés et
du coup j'étais persuadé que c'était
possible de l'aider de le guérir alors
ce jour là j'avais hérité de deux choses
la première c'était ces soi disant
pouvoir que je ne comprenais même pas et
la deuxième c'était cette croyance du
mythe du sauveur vous savez ce mythe qui
arrivent à vous convaincre que vous êtes
le sauveur et que vous pouvez tout faire
et que c'est vous qui allez tout faire
bien évidemment et simplement pour vous
montrer que que ce n'était pas
réalisable alors je dois vous parler
d'un moment où je me suis fait
totalement mais alors totalement
remettre à ma place et ce jour là
j'étais en train de parler avec une amie
à ma mère
j'étais vraiment content ce jour là
parce que je lui expliquais mes
objectifs je disais que j'allais tout
faire pour sauver mon frère car j'étais
convaincu qu'avec l'hypnose c'était
possible de faire des miracles
et devinez quoi
je m'attendais pas à une réponse
positive et là elle m'a sorti tu te
prend pour dieu qui es tu pour décider
s'il est heureux à sa place qui es tu
pour prendre les décisions à sa place
alors là ça a été
complètement terminée j'en avais fini
avec cette croyance et j'imagine que
certains d'entre vous peut être encore
aujourd'hui ont déjà porté ce genre de
fardeau des des responsabilités qui au
final ne vous appartiennent même pas en
réalité
et maintenant donc les années les années
sont passées le temps est passé et bien
plus tard j'ai dû mettre mes études sur
pause car comme vous l'aurez deviné je
n'ai pas le premier de ma classe et
simplement à ce moment là j'ai fait une
découverte j'ai découvert la
programmation neuro linguistique et
qu'est ce que ça veut dire plus
simplement ça veut dire comment
influencer une personne et ce qui m'a le
plus marqué avec cette méthode c'est la
figure d'autorité vous savez celle qui
montre qui tient réellement les ficelles
car toute notre vie on se retrouve
bombardé de croyance d'à priori de
préjugés de commentaires négatifs et
toutes ces personnes
n'ont même pas idée de l'impact que les
mots peuvent avoir à quel point un
simple mot me bouleverser voire détruire
la vie d'une personne et c'est pour ça
que je vous invite maintenant à
simplement prendre conscience que tous
les jours chaque fois que vous ouvrez
votre bouche vous pouvez avoir de
l'influencé sur quelqu'un vous pouvez
croiser quelqu'un dans la rue et changer
sa vie littéralement
alors maintenant pour vous donner un
exemple on dit aux filles dès leur plus
jeune âge qu'elles doivent être belle
alors qu'on ne dit pas aux garçons
qu'ils doivent être beau et le résultat
de tout ça c'est qu'il ya des femmes qui
se retrouvent complexé toute leur vie
car elle était convaincue qu'elle devait
respecter leur croyance qu'ils avaient
depuis leur plus jeune âge alors ce qui
est important de comprendre c'est qu'en
fait avec ses ficelles qui vous voyait
donc ses ficelles blanche ses ficelles
rouge on va supposer dans ce cadre là
que les faisselles rouges sont les
mauvaises croyance c'est de devoir qu'en
fait vous pouvez transformer vos
faiblesses vos plus grandes faiblesses
en vo plus grande force
ce simplement en coupant les ficelles
rouge et lorsque vous avez fait ça après
vous pouvez continuer d'avancer et
continuer d'entretenir votre jardin
intérieur maintenant imaginez que vous
faites du foot c'est votre passion à
faire de votre carrière de foot et là il
ya cristiano ronaldo qui vous a vus
jouer qui vient vers vous et qui vous
dit qu'il aime votre style de jeu
ça ne va pas du tout vous impacté de la
même façon que si c'est la mère d'un de
vos camarades de foot qui vous a vus
jouer qui vous dit la même chose
n'est-ce pas et pourtant dans les deux
cas il s'agit d'un compliment il s'agit
de quelque chose de positif mais la
différence c'est l'influencé qui va
parler et maintenant j'aimerais vous
proposer un petit exercice
d'introspection
sait rien de compliqué c'est juste un
exercice qui va vous permettre d'aller
dans votre jardin un regard des
différentes choses pour modifier ce qui
a modifié tout simplement alors repensé
à rappelez vous de cette croyance
négative qui vous a impacté qui s'est
transformée en franc chercher un petit
peu si jamais vous l'avez pas on est un
petit temps et maintenant une fois que
vous l'avez posez vous la question si
c'est vraiment quelque chose de négatif
car si c'est le cas c'est peut-être le
moment de vous en débarrasser
super et maintenant
fermez vos yeux
fermez vos yeux et simplement imaginer
penser à cette croyance visualiser la
super d'avoir une couleur et avoir une
odeur elle peut avoir une sensation peu
importe et maintenant
transformer la imaginer qu'elle prend la
forme d'une ficelle
penser qu'elle prend à cette formule 1
et dans votre main à votre meilleure
main vous avez une incroyable paire de
ciseaux une paire de ciseaux mais alors
vous n'avez jamais vu ça de vote via les
magnifiques et vous prenez cette paire
et vous couper cette ficelle vous l'a
coupée afin de vous libérer
vous libérer une bonne fois pour toutes
de cette croyance
et lorsque c'est fait
monsieur
ça fait du bien n'est ce pas de se
sentir libéré plus léger
la prochaine fois que vous allez vous
dire que vous êtes incapable que vous
pouvez pas y arriver que vous ne serez
pas à la hauteur
osez vous réellement la question si
c'est une incapacité physique concrètes
quelque chose qui est complètement
impossible inconcevable ou si c'est pas
plutôt une incapacité psychiques telles
qu'une croyance que vous avez entendu
ancré à l'intérieur de vous peu importe
à quel moment car si c'est une croyance
vous pouvez répéter ce genre d'exercice
revenir à l'intérieur de vous afin de
transformer vos faiblesses en forces
et sur ce
merci à tous et bon jardinage
[Applaudissements]